comme vous venez de l'entendre
j'ai gagné la médaille d'or des
championnats du monde en parlera
climbing donc en handi escalade en
français il ya quatre ans bientôt
mais ce soir je suis vous parlez de
dunes des choses dont lesquelles je suis
la plus fière
et curieusement c'est pas d'avoir gagné
une médaille d'or aux championnats du
monde ce dont je suis la plus fière et
ce que j'ai envie de partager avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt mon cheminement
comment j'en suis arrivée à atteindre
mes objectifs
qu'est ce qui m'a poussé à faire ça et
surtout comment j'y ai cru comment j'ai
osé et comment j'y suis arrivé faire de
sa passion un métier
ça a été un de mes objectifs principaux
depuis depuis très longtemps
et enfin comme vous l'avez sûrement
remarqué ma passion celle escalade alors
l'escaladent en falaise comme ici où
l'escaladé en salle
j'ai commencé à faire des escalades en
milieu naturel
par ma mère qui est française et des
gorges du tarn pour ceux qui connaissent
et c'est vraiment un endroit où c'est
vraiment propice à l escalade il ya
plein de rochers ya plein de falaise et
c'est magnifique
donc ma vie a été de baignés par l'
escalade
ça m'a appris énormément de choses sur
le goût de l'effort sur atteindre des
objectifs
comment malgré les difficultés et
finalement on dit en arrivant on arrive
au sommet alors ma vie a été bercée par
l'escaladé mais aussi par le handicap
donc moi je finis avec une jambe qui est
plus courte que l'autre c'est une
malformation de naissance donc je suis
né comme ça et j'ai dû faire avec
alors au début voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya
des il ya des contraintes il ya des
difficultés
et quand j'étais petit je me rendais pas
tellement content de tout ça moi j'avais
j'avais ma vie d'enfant aussi à vivre et
donc je m'épanouis c'est beaucoup grâce
à l' escalade
l'escaladé est un sport qui pour moi
m'a aidé dans le sens où je pouvais
pratiquer avec des gens tout à fait
valide et donc ça m'a permis de pouvoir
être confronté aux autres et ça a été
pour moi une richesse énorme et j'en ai
appris plein plein de choses positives
qui m'a permis toutes ces choses m'ont
permis aussi de pouvoir évoluer dans mon
handicap
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que le
le handicap que j'ai c'est quelque chose
qui est visible mais que toute ma vie en
fait je me suis rendu compte plus tard
que j'ai toujours fait tout pour le
cacher je mettais des pantalons je me
mettais pas trop en maillot enfin voilà
et j'ai fait des études dans le social
je te ment pour pouvoir transmettre tout
ce que j'avais appris de l' escalade et
du handicap aussi quand même emma mon
objectif c'était de pouvoir allier
l'escaladent donc ce sport à 1 à des
fins sociales donc que ce soit dans le
milieu du handicap mais aussi dans la
réinsertion ou avec des gens clients qui
avaient besoin de se prouver à eux mêmes
qu'ils étaient capables de faire de
faire des grandes choses et donc pour
pouvoir
arriver à ça j'ai décidé de partir en
france tout simplement parce que en
france il ya quand même plus de rochers
et la météo est un petit peu plus
clémentes qu'ici et c'est plus facile
quoi donc je décide de quitter mon
boulot mon appart j'ai toutes mes
caisses tout ça je pars en france
c'était plus ou moins il ya en 2012 et
je reste quelques mois histoire de
savoir exactement où je vais m'installer
ce que je vais faire ou est-ce que je
vais travailler tout ça je reviens en
belgique pour venir chercher toutes mes
caisses et là le club alpin m'appelle et
me dit oh you die c'est vraiment dommage
que tu partes parce que on a un projet
en un projet pour toi on a pensé à toi
on voudrait développer en tout cas créé
le handi escalade en belgique
et on voudrait que tu représentes la
belgique au niveau international pour
les compétitions
alors le ti fock et moi ça fait trente
ans que je suis en belgique et le jour
où je décide de partir mais pourquoi
pourquoi finalement ça tombe là à ce
moment là donc j'ai dû faire un choix un
choix parce que
voilà je devais un peu laissé tomber mon
idée mon objectif et puis finalement il
y avait quand même quelque chose
d'important qui allait peut-être pouvoir
se passer
donc je fais mon choix je reste en
belgique et en fait finalement j'ai bien
fait parce que quelques semaines plus
tard j'ai un coup de téléphone d'un
journaliste de la rtbf qui m'appellent
et qui me dit voilà on a un projet c'est
de faire l'ascension du mont blanc avec
une équipe mixte donc une équipe où il
ya des personnes valides et personnes
moins valides
notre objectif est évidemment c'est
d'arriver au sommet du mont blanc pour
l'opération cap 48 donc pour pouvoir
récolter des fonds pour cap 48 alors
tout de suite je dis oui évidemment le
mont blanc
enfin je vais avoir 30 ans et c'est
quelque chose que
que je rêve depuis depuis longtemps moi
qui passe ma vie à grimper oui
évidemment que je dis oui et puis en
fait en raccrochant jeudi 1 mais c'est
quand même ce que mon bol en quoi c'est
quand même le sommet de l'europe
moi je fais des petits le petit rocher
en france en belgique au luxembourg et
je me retrouvais l'arquois alors au
début moi j'ai jamais fait d'alpinisme
je n'ai jamais mis crampes ou jamais
vraiment marcher dans la neige
je sais pas je dis je vais voir on verra
bien je me lance dans l'aventuré je vais
je prends la décision de participer et
advienne que pourra donc phase ii
d'entraînement alors on nous dit il faut
monter les escaliers descendre les
escaliers monter les escaliers parce que
la principale difficulté du mont blanc
c'est évidemment les dénivelés en plus
de l'attitude du froid et tout ça donc
moi pour mon handicap
il y avait deux choses qui était
vraiment compliqué c'est au niveau des
aspects techniques
évidemment avec ce genre d'appareil âge
je pouvais pas mettre de chaussures de
montagne de chaussures d'alpinisme et
donc sa rentrée n'est pas mal de soucis
par exemple pour mettre des crampons
tout simplement en les crampons c'est
quoi
c'est peut-être tout ce que c'est des
grands ponts dont il ya des pics qui
sont vers le bas pour vraiment bien
adhérer sur la neige quand la pente est
raide
il ya des pics qui sont vers le devant
pour pouvoir vraiment bien chaud était
dans la neige est resté bien accrochés à
leur principale difficulté c'est de ne
pas se blesser parce que c'est ça arrive
assez souvent qu'on ce qu'on se donne
des coups dans les mollets de deux de
plat ne pas blesser les autres
évidemment et comment installer des
crampons sur des chaussures qui sont pas
adaptés enfin voilà ça a été tout un
bazar
deuxième difficulté mais aussi par
exemple moi mon truc mais comme vous le
savez tous et c'est le rocher pis là je
me retrouvais dans un univers où bédié
avait que de la neige quoi en moi la
neige c'est quand même pas évident et
dès qu'il y avait des petits bouts de
cailloux ou des petits bouts de rochers
mais je passais par là plutôt que de
passer dans la neige alors que tous les
autres passez dans la neige
donc il va falloir adapter adapté adapté
et deuxième difficulté que j'ai voilà
que je me rendais pas très très trop
content au début c'est tout l'aspect
médiatique la piège médiatique parce que
cette cette ascension allait faire
l'objet d'un documentaire qui allait
passer sur la rtbf
je le savais depuis le départ et ça
voulait dire que je vais faire linverse
que ce que je faisais tout le temps
d'habitude donc d'habitude je me cachais
quand même souvent donc je faisais ma
vie mais en même temps les gens savaient
pas trop ce que j'avais et savais que je
pourrais tu aimes et même mes amis
proches
il y en a plein qui savait pas ce que
j'avais et puis là je savais que
l'objectif c'était pour cap 48 dont qui
qui qui vient en aide et qui récolte des
fonds pour le handicap
je savais que j'allais devoir me
m'exposer est racontée est aussi
expliqué voilà qu'est ce qui est
difficile qu'est ce qu'il n'est pas et
pour moi ça a été une énorme démarche en
tout cas dans ma dans ma vie parce que
c'est quelque chose dont je n'ai pas du
tout du tout l'habitude de faire donc
ces deux difficultés là finalement on
est tous partis dans les alpes première
fois de ma vie que je me mettais les
pieds dans les alpes à chamonix on a
fait des petits des petits jours
d'acclimatation puis on est parti faire
l'ascension et on n'a pas réussi à
arriver au sommet à cause des conditions
climatiques donc on est arrivé au refuge
du goûter pour ceux qui connaissent qui
est à plus ou moins 1 3803 1900 et là on
a dû faire demi tour parce que parce
qu'il y avait des orages qui allait
arriver enfin bref on c'était impossible
de pouvoir monter et c'est impossible
pour nous c'était aussi un possible pour
tous les autres qui étaient là et ça
c'est un côté rassurant on se dit bon on
est quand même arrivé jusqu'ici c'était
pas facile on a quand même dû donner pas
mal et finalement
on se rend compte que on est tous dans
le même bateau handicap ou pas
handicaper quand on est tous obligés de
redescendre à cause de la météo
il ya vraiment deux choses que j'ai
retenu de cette aventure et deux choses
qui m'ont quand même suivi aussi pendant
pendant cette aventure et même après la
première chose ça se résume en quatre
mots quatre mots c'est y croire parce
que quand on a un projet si on n'y croit
pas on va arriver jusqu au milieu et
puis on va laisser tomber
donc quelque chose qui est vraiment très
important qui moi m'a en tout cas m'a
beaucoup aidé c'est le fait d'y croire
je vois le sommet je me dis ok j'y crois
première chose deuxième chose c'est osé
évidemment osé prendre la décision et se
dire ok j'y crois maintenant va falloir
y aller quoi hein
il ya un temps pour méditer réfléchir
tous appuyé un temps où on se dit ok j'y
vais
troisième chose c'est essayer ça va
évidemment c'est il faut essayer
et puis si ça marche pour mieux
évidemment si ça marche pas ne pas avoir
peur et ne pas hésiter à recommencer
alors recommencer c'est pas juste
recommencer dans la même ligne mais
c'est aussi savoir prendre du recul et
savoir sortir des sentiers battus donc
recommencer essayez d'analyser pourquoi
ça n'a pas fonctionné
et puis par exemple je prends l'exemple
du mont blanc
on a pris la voie normale au mont blanc
donc c'est la voie la plus classique
en tout cas celle où la plupart des gens
qui valait le sommet passe par cette
voie là seulement moi voilà il y avait
plein de l'endroit où s'était pas
vraiment adapté
à mon handicap ma façon de voir les
choses ma façon de d'évoluer en
montagnes et donc finalement mon
parcours à moi il ressemble un peu à
celui là l'objectif est tout à fait le
même
c'est le sommet sauf que la route n'est
pas la même alors certes elle est plus
longue mais j'ai appris énormément de
choses aussi j'ai rencontré d'autres
gens gg voilà je suis sorti des sentiers
battus et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui m'a c'est un message en tout
cas que j'ai envie de vous faire passer
et c'est quelque chose qui m'a aidé
énormément pendant l'ascension du mont
blanc mais aussi par après parce que
donc on est redescendu tout ça et deux
semaines plus tard moi qui étais jamais
allé à chamonix je me retrouve à
chamonix
mais pour une compétition alors le club
alpin m'a dit écoute voilà on inscrit à
une compétition la première de ma vie où
je savais pas du tout ce que c'était une
compétition d'escaladé je grimpais tpi
depuis tout le temps mais pas du tout en
mode
je vais gagner quoi est bon je vais à
chamonix
j'avais fait le mont-blanc deux semaines
avant donc jeter encore un peu j'avais
trop de globules rouges je pense encore
j'étais à fond quoi et en même temps je
me suis dit j'y vais j'ai pas de
pression parce que de toute façon si je
perds je perds mais les gens me
connaissent quand même pas et j'y vais
pour m'amuser quoi ce que j'aime c'est
grimpe et puis là on m'offre on m'offre
des voix énorme enfin c'est magnifique
alors ce que je savais pas c'est
l'ampleur d'une compétition alors
l'ampleur d'une compétition pour vous
donner une idée ça ressemble à ça alors
c'est sûr que l'on arrive l'heure on se
dit quand même d'accord le mont blanc il
est tous là au hockey mûri quand même et
quand même grand pile quand même des
versants aussi donc il ya plein de gens
enfin truc de fou mais bon voilà je vais
quand même essayer je suis monté à 3800
mètres 15 16 mètres ça devrait peut-être
aller on verra bien quoi et donc j'ai
fait cette j'ai fait cette compétition
en étant vraiment en mode touriste et
je me suis retrouvé sur la première
marche du podium et là je me suis dit
c'est quand même fou j'ai pris une
décision il ya un an il ya deux ans et
voilà où je suis aujourd'hui sur la
première marche d'un championnat
d'europe moi qui avais jamais fait de
compétition de ma vie c'est moi je
comprenais pas très bien d'ailleurs
la brabançonne résonner dans chamonix
c'était c'était top quoi et je me suis
dit bon allez y à côté d'eux quand même
moyen de d'évoluer et puis de me lancer
vraiment là dedans et finalement mon
objectif qui au départ était de faire de
ma passion un métier
mais plus d'un dans le premier sens où
je l'entendais au début mon objectif a
été atteint dans le sens où j'ai fait de
ma passion un métier pas exactement
comme celui que je voulais faire au
départ peut-être si ça se trouve je le
ferai plus tard
mais dans ce cadre-là de compétition et
puis de pouvoir partager aux gens tout
ce que j'ai pu vivre et ce goût de
l'effort et puis et puis voilà mon mon
message vraiment important que je
voulais vous dire ce soir
c'est d'une part partir du moment où
vous avez un objectif et vous voulez
atteindre un sommet peu importe lequel
c'est le signal de botrange ou montblanc
finalement c'est si tous les deux des
sommets il faut y aller il faut y croire
et il faut oser y aller
et si ça marche pas une fois qu'on a
essayé ne pas hésiter à recommencer il
faut pas avoir peur de recommencer
c'est pas vraiment un échec une dernière
phrase qui va être la conclusion de la
conférence ici c'est celle ci si le plan
a ne marche pas il ya vingt-cinq autres
lettres dans l'alphabet prix encore les
chiffres et tout ce qu'on veut donc il
n'ya plus qu'à quoi
voilà merci beaucoup